хтось наших арум і
і говорив у маленька кімнатка
постав собі з меблями тобто та шафа
стоїть диван стіл все викинули все тут
великий могильник у межах міста
величезний нам цей піщаний масив під 6
мікрорайон того після аварії
використовували як могильник місце
поховання холодильників там із квартир
меблів якихось особистих речей тощо
ну а ми тут по прямий гідний
кілометра до станції в той бік один
з найближчих районів тому тут було
брудно та тотальна був один активація
тут у нас залишилося дуже мало
елементи мого конструктора торшери
але чути того дня, коли все сталося
я був школою що ми бігали дивитись на
пожежа не вразила абсолютно зараз
багато хто розповідає про гігантський зал
виду небо я не виключаю що напевно
було але не в той момент, коли ми прийшли
коли ми прийшли було серпанок станція
затягнуте як туманом у принципі нічого
цікавого ми не побачили зате гелікоптери
почали літати над головами військові
величезне з якимись прив'язаними
каструлями та ось це було цікаво
район найближчих станцій та піддавався
просто тотальної зачистки
з вікон викидати меблі холодильники
і все це потім поховалося цінності
у нас особливих не було тому вкрасти
ніхто нічого там не вкрали.
викинули мамі вдалося вона поверталася
у травні 86 у 6 вивести якісь там і
фотоальбом
звідси кілька шапок своїх на жаль
на них вивезла які потім ми створили
купу проблем зі здоров'ям але ось альбоми
це ну знов-таки це пам'ять які не
давала їм не забути про місто і в
якомусь сенсі сприяло в результаті
повернення сюди
для себе відзначав дивовижну штуку я
взагалі не пам'ятаю її завари мені було
десять років хлопцем від ну здавалося б
з прип'яті у очевидне у ліворуч будинком
висотного тобто повинен був
цікавитися а що ж це таке але ось
хоч убий не пам'ятаю взагалі тобто я його
для себе відкрив коли почав їздити зону
після аварії вже значно пізніше у 90
причому об'єкта ж був за інерцією закритий
вже після розвалу союзу армії нема ну
було заборонено значить ну ще забороняємо я
після аварії дуже хотів повернутися то на
багато років було мені місто
постійно снився і але я був хлопчиськом
це було в принципі неможливо
дозові навантаження
неповнолітнім зону зараз не можна і
я маму просив допомогти мені з цим вона
[музика]
говорила там хоча б 16 років dash
дій та ну що ти будемо думати і
коли мені виповнилося 16 це було нас
вже
92 я ну носив на маму знову ти обіцяла
до водила
і вона домовилася якось зі своїм
колишнім колегою з палацу культури
енергетик Саша Демидова
він на той час уже був директором
телебачення міста славутич
що ви не взяли мене з собою коли
поїдуть знімати якусь там сюжету і ось
зима
92 ми через славутич їдемо зону на
автобус я не знаю що розповідали
коли guys на про це поліція тоді
що це за пацан сидить ну якось вони
це питання вирішили мене просто не
помічали демонстративно мене завезли до
прип'ять залишили там та вони поїхали
знімати свій сюжет на станцію і я майже
п'ять годин один про бродив містом
ходив скрізь своїми місцями свого
дитинства
більшу частину поїздки просто ревнув
це був найважчий психологічний
візит та й напевно ось тільки після
це до цієї подорожі я зрозумів для себе
що нам нікуди повертатися до цього все
ще вірив сподівався що але повернемося тим
не менше це подорож на та зумовило
мабуть
то чим я займаюся знайшов свій спосіб
повертався
є моє уявлення вона може
відрізнятися від того, що хочемо чого до чого
прагне держава україна
я хотів би однозначно цю територію
взагалі якщо говорити про зону бачити як
муту чим вона вже де-факто є
просто на
з юридичним статусом це унікальний
заповідник просто неба
природа показує що незважаючи і навіть
швидше всупереч зусиллям людини вона все
і відновлюється і місія прип'яти
і ось у цьому контексті глобальному
екологічному мабуть що може навіть
не екологія навколишнього середовища, а швидше
екологія душі людини це ось місце в
якому кожна людина може якщо
захоче скласти себе відчути те
що пережили люди, які тут жили
поставити себе на їхнє місце уявити
собі щось могло б статися і з його
містом пропустити через себе і в
надалі жити так, щоб після нього не
залишалися мертві міста
[музика]
в